[Musique]
le thème famille avec nous ce soir c'est
super carrière jean jacques bour
à
bernard le mois
[Applaudissements]
vive elia
j'ai joué
marie et laurent baffie
[Applaudissements]
alors premier invité ce soir ils
partagent le même lit et le même métier
fabre et
cela fabrice éboué et ramzy bedia
chez jean jacques bourdin milla
autres terriens invité ce soir notre tt
ou de la semaine on fait notre invité
bas ou steak tu étais passé hastert à
bernac robert charlebois
[Applaudissements]
ce soir ils sont ici pour une comédie
étonnante une comédie comme on n'en fait
plus une comédie dont on rêvait une
comédie drôle
ça risque de choquer le public
n'était pas du tout habituée aux
comédies drôle est ce que vous espérez
fabrique se remet en selle à la mode des
comédies drôle oui c'est vrai
notre deuxième terrienne de ce soir est
sans doute ce que le tchad a fait de
mieux avec la pologne anaïs malines
en p4 après alex vizorek nous
accueillerons notre terrienne du samedi
soir marine barnérias
à 21 ans elle apprend qu'elle a eues
l'ex les roses en plaques à 22 elle
décide de partir tout seul faire le tour
du monde une sacrée fille voilà
l'émission s'appelle salut les terriens
le groupe
le hashtag tlt
[Musique]
je sais
et maintenant voici mon cdd tom villa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on sera tous tout le monde est venu en
coupe ce soir là même le rend la
surveillance et s'est cassé les moyens
ya catherine qui va venir ces mots
rhinocéros voilà [__] de bonne
ambiance non premier invité thierry se
voit déjà tellement peu la semaine qui
sont obligés de venir en couple à la
télé c'est jean jacques bourdin et on y
va c'est beaucoup
jean jacques bourdin le matinalier drm
c'est depuis 16 ans voilà vous présentez
bourdin direct 16 ans la jean jacques
bourdin pour marine le pen c'est un peu
son jacques martin il l'a connue toute
petite et l'a vu grandir voilà c'est
l'homme qui interroge les politiques un
peu à la manière d'un commissaire des
stups s'il manque plus que la langue
dans la gueule écoute bottin derrière la
tête c'est à bourdin qui faisaient ces
questions un peu cache un peu piège vous
les faites plus d'ailleurs c'est dommage
vous aviez posé la question olivier
besancenot combien font 9 x 8 et il
avait refusé de vous répondre pourtant
la réponse est facile c'est le nombre de
communistes qui restent en france
[Applaudissements]
tif tiff question jean jacques bourdin
jean jacques bourdin quelle est la
fréquence de mcr vernon dans l'eure
aucune idée
mais alors aucune idée c'est vrai la
france veut savoir je sais je ne sais
pas j'assume eh ben c'est 103 points
comme à paris anne nivat bonsoir
arrière et adore ses portraits de mon
bain que tout le monde s'évertue à faire
et qui sont totalement faux c'est quoi
j'adore ça mais je vous dirai pas la
vérité médicale à trouver vous êtes
ensemble depuis 13 ans au nom depuis
deux minutes depuis c'était bien de
sorte depuis 14 ans 14 ans 4
14 ans et je m'en rends compte qu'ils
ont jamais pris le petit déjeuner
ensemble c'est donc pour vous faire
rêver c'est pas la tour d'argent c'est
la brio
genval
83 60 89 c'est pas votre digicode
chérissent éléments sur un de notre
prochaine invitée c'est anaïs malisse
est bouclé
un ami smaghi mannequin voilà vous avez
été repéré dans un musée calme-toi
la regarde aller sauter d'un jeune
enfant et timmy attention fond c'est que
ce soir ce n'est pas ramzy c'est ramzy
bedia
oct l'acteur il ya deux il y en a deux
balles que tard à
[Rires]
nice elle a été repéré dans la rue ce
stade dans un pub ouais il est où ce
peuple sans déconner quand le vieux nice
si l'om est serveuse sans déconner son
pantalon et son rock rock c'est
dégueulasse non vous êtes la fille d'une
mère tchadienne et n'a pas pas quoi le
nez voilà comment est ce qu'on peut être
contre la mixité en voyant anaïs mali
hausse en voyant fabrice je peux
comprendre mais en voilà
il y avait la fashion week qui s'est
terminée cette semaine à paris je vous
donne quelques chiffres de la fashion
week mille quatre cent trente six paires
de chaussures 8 174 kg de maquillage
3428 tenues et deux grappes de raisin
pour nourrir toute
notre quatrième invité physiquement
c'est un petit peu comme si eddy
mitchell avait couché avec michel berger
merci qui merci et dit michel c'est
robert charlebois
robert charlebois le chanteur le
jugement d'hier à montréal ça fait 40
ans qu'il doit partir à montréal et une
grève et repenser comment ça se passe
sans déconner vous avez déclaré j'ai un
sens de l'humour à toute épreuve bon on
va voir ça et non robert ça fait
cinquante ans de carrière c'est un peu
le moment où on fait des fois des des
best-of voilà pour pour payer ses impôts
alors que vous pas du tout vous faites
des concerts électro acoustique qui
reprennent au plus grand titre c'est ce
que je disais donc les impôts par doro
temps
pour terminer je vous demande applaudir
très fort monsieur fabrice éboué
monsieur ramzy bedia
[Applaudissements]
parisi qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
allez retrouver chez fabrice que vous
aviez perdu chez erika par les cheveux
évidemment
j'y retrouvais le confie jt tout de
suite en fait c'est vrai ouais c'est ils
sont très très semblables eric et
fabrice ils viennent pour le film de
fabrice qui s'appelle coexister voilà
c'est l'histoire d'un rabbin d'un imam
et d'un prêtre mais ils sont pas dans un
avion et l'imam ne vole pas la montre du
prêtre le film fait cohabiter un peu des
musulmans des catholiques et des juifs
donc pour vous c'est une comédie pour
nadine morano c'est un film d'horreur
granby il se transforme en animal blessé
un peu par opportunisme dans le film
wall a mangé du pao buvait de l'alcool
voilà vous avez été en kabylie pour
préparer le rôle non non non
et fabrice sûr qu utiliser coexister va
c'est le sourire il existe dicko
excisées ce qui était très gênant
ans fabrice et le scénariste l'acteur le
réalisateur et le coproducteur donc en
fait sur le film le juif c'est pas le
rabbin c'est fabrice évidemment mais non
on peut un faux pas on applaudissait
paraît plausible c'est pas faux pas être
choqué on peut rire des religions valade
et parce que les juifs par exemple c'est
la seule religion qui à son humour
l'humour juif et à l'humour musulmans
vieillit plus elle expliqué il n'ya pas
l'humour cateau ça c'est quoi un humour
cateau ça sera un prêtre qui va avoir un
enfant pour lui dire qu'il ya un autre
petit jésus mais que celui-ci faut en
parler à personne mais on peut se poser
la question voyez tirée finalement c'est
le problème des religions c'est qu'à la
base tout le monde voulait la paix mais
comme personne à la même religion et bat
tout le monde se bat pour savoir qui est
le meilleur ami imaginaire
[Applaudissements]
ici c'est johnny mon super
mandela
voilà fleurs
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il n'a quand même pas dit le principal
en ce qui me concerne c'est que ma
fonction c'est pas être femme de jean
jeune homme attend
quant à moi mais pour tous les autres il
l'a dit banco et le dresseur
on va en parler oui mais enfin ça peut
se dire aussi
comment on fait bah vous refaites
on va en parler reconnaît il l'a dit
pour tout le monde sauf pour moi moi
j'ai il n'a pas dit pourquoi j'étais là
je suis grand père on a tous des plans
infos regard ils ont mis tous les
immigrés du même côté on à brossard
à attendre a rappelé que tom rappelé tom
se fit la cité
médiévale et là c'est la fin du mois
la seule chose a pas dit un seul échec
par gounod ou de la merde je peux mais
la place de téléspectateurs il entend ça
au début de l'émission c'est clair bon
vous avez intérêt à rigoler
si vous le faites bien
parce que moi tu as dit que j'étais
moche et le
spectacle
non mais anne nivat vous vous venez pas
ce que vous avez écrit un livre aussi
qui s'appelle dans quelle france on vit
j'aimerais ça fait très bien quel
éditeur métier c'est d'aller voir sur le
terrain bien sûr mais non vous allez
faire un tour de france j'ai regardé
vous avez choisi de visiter civile
montluçon laval evreux lons le saunier
est lent et pour finir ajaccio mais à
part ça je suis reporter de guerre mais
bien sûr ça ouais ajaccio bien sûr on
est en place maintenant à nos thés au
top de la semaine
fabrice et ramzy re bonsoir
ici la voix
thierry je suis désolé le public ne veut
pas de ramzy bedia il réclame eric judor
fait le nécessaire est ce que cette voie
c'est pas françois rollin oui nairas
c'est le professeur à la
joue et cgt surgelés pack rostu la
creuse ni les piles étaient dans ton
film oui exactement le hibou rester bien
alors ça passe bien fabrice eram dit non
est-ce que je peux préciser une chose
même mais c'est bien l'arrêter nous
faire chier tout mal à démarrer cette
émission merde oui et non
m beck royal et là j'ai demandé à me
dire on vient habiller comment il
simplement je vis avec une chemise en
jeans il s'est mis en costume de maria
alors à c'est une heureuse aussi je vous
laisse sa chance et bien
depuis le début de la promo il ya ce
petit jeu et qu'il fallait craindre
comme ça l'avionique et on m'a dit que
j'étais moche crado je vais y aller la
croix là mais tout ça ça n'a pas empêché
de faire un super film troie
alors ça passe bien fabrice lundy sais
c'est pas comme lauren et laspalès par
exemple juste qu'il passerait moins bien
ou ailier a redit sa part eric et thomas
eric et omaha c'est pas mal ça jacquier
michel c'est bien
ramzy donc à un moment où vous avez
essayé de reformer
eric et ramzy mais avec eric zemmour
s'était pas mal on regarde le sketch
c'est pas d'avoir lu des livres excuse
moi d'avoir lu des livres vous entendez
quoi avec ça on dirait que vous me
reprochez de santé les auteurs très bien
je préfère citer des auteurs comme les
approprier sans les citer
la phrase
excusez moi moi d'avoir lu les livres
qu'est ce que ça vous sous-entend ça
sous-entend pas que moi je n'ai rien lu
ah non ça sous-entend pas d'accord merci
je sais rien
eyeka énervé et il me ment il me manque
ah ouais et déjà tirer dans les missions
qu'on vient de voir aux aviez mis les
trois immigrés du même côté droit et un
souci à chaque fois comme c'est le
ghetto et
son ami s'il n'y a pas la barrière il ya
quand même la barrière des langues on
les comprend pas bien
heureusement que pomme il singe de ce
côté ça aurait été limitée
ici tous les deux ce soir pour une
comédie drôle intitulé coexister écrite
et réalisée par vous fabrice éboué avec
vous avec jonathan cohen ramzy bedia
guillaume de tonquédec audrey lamy et
évidemment amelle chahbi et mathieu
seignez c'est vrai mais elle fait la
méchante bête il ferait la patronne de
la maison de disques ça commence comme
une blague carambar donc un lien bien un
curé un imam un rabbin sa chute mieux
alors en fait non c'est un producteur de
musique à la dérive qui décident de
monter un groupe constitué d'un curé
d'un rabbin un imam pour leur faire
chanter le vivre ensemble
ce qui bien entendu a provoqué une
avalanche de gags une avalanche de
vannes alors c'est très drôle ça je vous
dis franchement c'est rare que je
m'engage comme ça à la télévision
publiquement mais là je dois dire je me
suis marré du début à la fin alors il ya
ton québec donc le prêtre alors lui en
fait il ya tout le monde il est est
showbiz mais il a le toit de l'église à
refaire donc il accepte et c'est vrai
qu'il est génial dans l'abdomen gueule
de curé frotter des classes et un nom de
curé lieutenant du coup c'est le curé
voilà hier jonathan kent le rabbin alors
lui faisait partie d'un groupe qui
jouait dans les bar mitzvah et magic
robbins jusqu'au jour où son fait exprès
il a coupé la [__] d'un monde lors d'une
circoncision que je sens déjà permis des
tribus jamais remis et depuis il a une
phobie des petites saucisses knacki
jusqu'à
révéler comme ça alors on va en vendre
des tickets
et voilà vous êtes un imam fait ça
n'avait pas été un imam fait que vous
l'auriez pas jouer parce qu'il n'est pas
question non plus si ç'avait été comme
ça un vrai imams coin à la dérive comme
ça non je n'aurais pas fait je savoure
respect pour cette raison bien j'aurai
pas prêt non plus parce que tu aurais
jamais cru que qu'imam
alors vous êtes un musulman qui mangent
du porc qui boit de l'alcool qui baise à
tout va je suis un chanteur raté qui
chante dans des cabarets de miteux et la
proposition de fabrice
bien sûr je saute dessus parce que je
rêve de tourner je rêve de groupies et
je rêve l'alcool en plus ils bossent
dans une mosquée une fille qui s'appelle
mosquée jacques brel
j'ai jamais été dans une mosquée alors
vous avez eu l'idée du film avant
l'attentât du 13 novembre
vous avez failli renoncer fabrice et
puis vous avez pris la bonne décision au
départ j'ai hésité et puis je me suis
dit faut le faire il faut le faire et
puis c'est à la fois évidemment sur lui
lançant mais c'est une critique du vivre
ensemble aussi à ses heures qui est
devenu totalement galvaudé comme terme
maintenant tu achètes des couches a
toujours un petit noir un petit chinois
et un petit français dessus pour dire
t'as vu c'est super donc j'en avais un
peu marre je dis il faut se moquer tout
ça maintenant quoi ou très réussi alors
les parts s'est inspirée par un trio un
groupe créé par le père di falco en 2010
elle a deux en tôle sur les trois la
main qui pue curé série l'a découvert le
show business il est défroqué vous
saviez ça ouais c'est le plus jeune il
était séminariste à l'époque et suite à
la tournée il a dit finalement je veux
faire autre chose que prêtre ouais les
animateurs dans la centrale
aujourd'hui croit plus à la sacem quand
dieu
arrivé aussi sur direct 8 une émission
qui s'appelait les enfants d'abraham on
les regarde dans salut les terriens
à catholique un musulman un juif c'est
plus une émission de tennis et jérusalem
s'est bien passé dans les loges
malek rhein korcia pas ici donné que
c'est votre loge
c'est avant tout des retrouvailles entre
nous trois parce qu'on a eu pendant six
ans une émission qui manque cruellement
et si moi j'ai accepté de venir c'est
parce que je rêvais maintenant dans un
temps compliqué de pouvoir réaffirmé que
les chrétiens les musulmans les juifs
ont des choses à partager des grandes
questions d'actualité maintenant on
avait cette émission sur direct 8
pendant six ans et elle a arrêté au
moment je crois où elle serait le plus
nécessaire
voilà les enfants d'abraham qu'on avait
réuni à nouveau sur le plateau de salut
les terriens donc la loge de malek
chebel n'avait pas été annexées par
rhein korcia rassurez vous emma on va
regarder la bande annonce un jardin que
la bande annonce elle et hop on regarde
le jeu de musique pourquoi deux manches
musique est au point mort depuis deux
ans ils ont essayé de lancer des projets
artistiquement très ambitieux
ça c'est de la merde ça peut cartonner
si dans moins de six mois monsieur
musique n'a pas rempli l'olympia avec un
nouvel artiste il cédera sa place de
directeur
et pourquoi on fait pas ça un prêtre
un rabbin
un iman plus une gueule du monde réunis
sur scène pour chanter ensemble
non mais je rigole pas là
pour exister quelque chose qui vous lie
à la communauté juive mois s'est rappelé
jacob
j'ai dormi comme un bébé comme avec
je vous rappeler que nous sommes dans un
pays de culture chrétienne judéo
chrétien alors chrétienne les rois de
france n'était pas juste ça c'est
dommage parce que vaut mieux avoir
l'avis de couper plutôt que la tête
basse et mal
face à mulhouse est sur scène dans 5
minutes sociaux mon équipe et j'ai fait
les plus beaux gland de toutes les
hauts-de-seine je sais pas d'épater si
un fils est sain je suis pas je suis à
l'écouté in arms
bref on dirait un contrôleur ratp est
nord est censée être humain pas d'alcool
ont publié sur la tocnaye de barques
user du vin en lançant ses 20 ans elle
blanchit -
c'est no 15 minutes je suis prêt moi et
là on ne se trouver votre mosquée dans
le bal demain oui aux 9,4 la mosquée
jacques brel
là il faut savoir mettre ça soit à
l'épreuve
non non non non non mais ma foi est la
plus forte
ces deux causes et la semaine exact
ben on paie quoi cela se fait plaisir on
sort son ok personne ne bouge sale
[__] ça m'aide
jason
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était la peur le slt je retombe
après la pub en tout de suite
[Musique]
ramon soir les terrains du samu nous
sommes de retour sur terre toujours en
compagnie de jean jacques bourdin
fabrice éboué 26 mai bien mai robert
charlebois
d'anaïs mal et de londres puis
fabrice et ramzy re bonsoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà les samplers oecuménique quand on
passe un sampler on passe les trois
alors dieu dieu vous savez que dieu voit
tout dieu c'est tout il a vu le film il
en a pensé quoi dieu celui au dessus des
3 je vais vous le dire
j'ai beaucoup aimé
merci le film doit être bien parce que
d'habitude il envoie ton fils
alors vous qui vous êtes intéressé aux
trois religions vous nous conseillez
plutôt laquelle a
cessé facile quoi et qui les femmes je
conseille pas la religion catholique
spécialement ouais je sais pas ce que
c'est on a eu de retour de il ya un
évêque je crois qui est venu enfin qui
est venu enquêter pour savoir si les
aigles devait aller voir le film ils ont
dit c'est un peu trop olé olé pour new
eyes pour les évêques espagnols
qui jouent à lima à faux est-ce que vous
avez un avis sur la place de l'islam
dans la république
ou bien vous sentez que j'ai envie de
vous faire dire une connerie
je pense qu'il ya une place pour l'islam
dans la république voilà c'est pas une
connerie
c'est drôle vous avez été mais tous les
deux dans des écoles catholiques vous
votre père avait été éduqué par les
jésuites en afrique et dont c'était le
bénédicité à chaque repas j'allais à la
messe en latin et xynthia l'aumônerie du
lycée descartes est plutôt sympa c'est
là où j'ai fait mes premiers joints et
vous êtes allé à lourdes aussi j'ai fait
le frat plusieurs fois à lourdes 1 je
les fais deux fois je crois tu es
adolescents est en fait tu vas là-bas et
télécharger des délais les handicapés
aller jusqu'à la grotte qui est en
contrebas delà de la vie les reptiles
drop on était ados on était con et je
m'en rappelle le plus grand jeu c'était
celui qui l'achète fut longtemps les
fauteuils roulants dans la pente c'est
qu'il rattraper au dernier match voilà
mais on était aurait été très bête à ce
défaut mais quand même éducation
catholique est vrai aussi ramzy votre
père que j'ai connu le grand duc il a
inscrit à l'école catholique j'ai fait
toutes mes études avec l'autre
catholique je fais j'ai mes prières
avant de manger ce qui est
extraordinaire avec votre père c'est
qu'il a continué à travailler après sa
retraite pour vous permettre d'aller
dans cette école catholique exactement
moi je voulais pas mettre dans les codes
de la cité avait une école catholique à
côté et à travailler jusqu'à 80 85 ans
et malgré tout ça t'a rien de tout ça
pour ça tout ça pour ça que je fais mes
prières
lorsque j'ai oublié de dire c'est
qu'après deux ans d'absence fabrice vous
revenu sur scène avec votre nouveau
spectacle en tournée dans toute la
france vingt dates exceptionnelles à
partir du 26 janvier au théâtre de la
renaissance un nouveau spectacle j'ai
pas encore le titre for te dire vous
avez écrit quand même nom où elle écrit
j'ai commencé le rodéo moi tu es dans
une petite salle de 30 personnes donc je
serai fin prêt pour fin juillet
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant vous ne serez pas étonné
qu'on fasse un quiz qui a dit spécial
dieu
[Musique]
je vais donner les phrases il ya qui les
a écrites dieu est mort marx est mort et
moi mondiale n je ne me sens pas très
bien où dit m ramzy bedia un peu la
trouille à
dieu existe-t-elle
fascinant go
à 10 c sur france 2 léa salamé non c'est
un mec est génial sur france 2
quand on veut dire qu'on trouve un mec
est aussi génial tu as débat sébastien
bah oui voilà lundi ce
moment dieu existe tiens c'est pas mal
un ami à toi si dieu avait voulu comme à
la messe il aurait fait des bancs
d'église plus confortable les gars n'ont
un ami à moi ouais quelqu'un que tu
respecte beaucoup et je respecte
personne à ben laden
regardez pas ce que ben laden est née le
même jour que ramzi a ouais ouais ouais
ouais il n'y a pas de fumée sans feu
ce que je voulais mais
non c'est ton ami c'est un ami gens
viennent avec mon idole
dieu est gaulliste qui a dit ça marine
le pen non de gauche web de gauche
qu'elles le sont pour des mots dieu
créateur de tout responsable de rien
un génie qui a dit sa
grande haie je dis toi [__] et moi
non mais oui c'est moi
et oui oui mais c'était dans mon dico
bien sûr qui a gagné
ramzy monsieur no 6
[Applaudissements]
quand je me souviens d'ailleurs eric
zemmour
critiqué soi disant manque d'occupation
j'avais une veste rose a fait pour ça
qui m'a pas respecté le costume qui fait
tout en fait dit tu vas acheter au
je vais lui une marque très élevé ça
fait ça regarde non arrêté à nantes et
vannes oc ii
et
maintenant on passe à nos invités
polémique de la semaine
mais
[Musique]
alors en 2001 jean jacques bourdin re
bonsoir
quand vous êtes reporter de guerre
auteur d'une dizaine de livres dont
chienne de guerre prix albert londres en
2000 après l'afghanistan la tchétchénie
l'irak la syrie vous portez pour la
première fois votre regard sur
l'hexagone et ça donne dans quelle
france convie en poche chez plurielles
le 9 octobre jean jacques bourdin vous
êtes le mari dame
[Musique]
c'est vraiment être la première oui bien
solidaire on ne lâchera pas
tu dois ranchi [__] aig est en forme
depuis le 14 ans voilà alors rmc bfmtv
en revanche ça fait 16 ans et vous
présenter tous les matins dans bourdin
direct du lundi au vendredi de 6h à 10h
vous êtes rencontrés en 2004 devant les
caméras and à l'époque vous viviez en
russie vous étiez en france pour la
sortie de lendemain de guerre et peut
être attaché de presse vous conseille de
faire bourdin ce n'est pas qui c'était
voilà mon avis aux clients qui excuse et
vous jean-jacques nous n'avions aucune
envie de la recevoir vous êtes battus
contre votre équipe à l'époque vous
dites que l'afghanistan l'irak ne s'est
pas vente c'est clair l'asie centrale ça
fait ch et ou non non surtout faut dire
une chose assez qui vous avait déjà
interviewé une fois sur rmc et vous
aviez trouvé qu'elle était sèche j'avais
dit elle a du caractère alain ducasse ça
m'avait intrigué par les reptiles
caractère vous propose de l'interviewer
vous dit ouh là là
j'ai dit bon
l'afghanistan encore l'afghanistan mois
la marche mais oui c'est vrai j'avais
fait beau et donc sincèrement et
honnêtement l'interview mieux parce que
louis hachette presse dit non non elle
est formée à la radio 1 il n'y avait pas
de caméra vous dit anne nivat vous dites
il m'a alpaguer c'est à dire que bourdin
ne séduit pas ils alpague
à hilla le pag anne nivat et je lui
demande son numéro de téléphone
rien d'original très franchement ça n'a
rien changé c'est la même chose dans ce
bas vous le rocher guy bourdin vous
courent après avec vous repartez quant à
moscou vous repartez quand moscou est
est-ce qu'on peut se voir avant votre
nom de derry n'ai pas déjeuné ensemble
elle n'a pas dit non mais non mais c'est
magnifique quand ça nous arrive ça bah
oui c'est magnifique
ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça ressemble à une comédie romantique
mais dans les bureaux de rmc si on
connaît rmc honnêtement c'est moins
drôle que un c'est certain je savais
qu'il ya derrière le fumeur je sais pas
qui mêle buzzer
alors comme dans la vraie vie il nous
fait aussi ses questions piège là à ces
questions pièges moi je trouve qu'il ya
pas de questions qui n'ont alors y'a
quand même il ya un très grand serviteur
5e tettey hausse alors je suis désolé la
ja c'est par pièce moi je trouve que
tout le monde doit tout assumer après
coup le problème c'est que dans les
médias on joue la comédie on fait de la
com etc etc ce qu'il faut dire quand
même c'est que la question à sarkozy sur
les sunnites et les chiites c'est une
question à vous
voilà je lui souffre des questions le
souffle et les questions et pas les
pires jean-jacques à celle là c'est une
fille
comme il ya toujours une fin mais
toujours toujours alors la pire question
qui vous est posée est ce que c'est tu
veux m'épouser il m'a demandé c'est même
pas d'ailleurs comment
commence à vous et à
vous
la voulez être sûr votre fils
c'est en fait à quoi bon alors je suis
sûr que si vous avez le malheur de ne
pas répondre à l'une de ces questions du
genre on mange quoi ce soir par exemple
l'excellent qui fait la cuisine mais
parce que sinon il serait capable
lui que se demande comment en tous les
cas je pense effectivement qu'une femme
qui n'aurait pas vécu la guerre les
bombardements rue du mal à supporter
pour jacques bourdin
alors en même temps vous vous défendez
super bien je suis obligé de défendre et
on regarde
pas bonjour oui bonjour oui spécialiste
de la russie grand reporter
anne qui est ma femme je dis toujours
pas ce que tu sais on sait jamais après
il ya des mauvaises langues qui pourrait
dire que
directes 16 direct d'appétit pour pas
lui faire perdre deux tours il a pas
perdu de temps là c'était pour moi annie
wable la main sur reporter de guerre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en tant que reporter de guerre vous
pensez quoi des journalistes qui
préfèrent rester bien au chaud dans un
studio a interviewé des politiques ben
écoutez je ne sais pas j'en connais pas
trop
non bien je pense qu'il faut de tout
pour faire du journalisme et nous avons
une façon de travailler très différentes
mais en face complète il faut c'est vrai
que le plus gros risque de bourdin sait
recevoir un postillon d'un invité dans
la vie ça peut arriver alors en faire
une interview les amours
[Musique]
allez on se lave à quelle heure le matin
4 heures 15 au [__] quel est son
parfum préféré bon j'arrête non mais moi
je n'ai pas pas pour autant pas de
parfum mettez pas de parfum mais selon
jacky rares maçons les reporter de
guerre ne met pas parfait non je ne suis
pas standard reporter de guerre je parle
que en mon nom pour vous vidéo un peu d
eau comme un match en mangeant les
montagnes c'est vrai pour passe d'être
humaines fortes charges et amis quelle
façon sont bloqués
[Applaudissements]
il laisse aller
ma chanson préférée ces chefs
n'étaient pas tous n'étaient pas tous à
jeff kelly mission qu'il voudrait
présenter
c'est une émission qui n'existe plus
ouais laquelle droit de réponse aux
plaques ah bah ouais ouais c'est une
très bonne et changera de la maison t'as
pas de réponse
[Applaudissements]
jean jacques cottel lui matelly le
tournage va se connaît ancien de guerre
et c'est un livre formidable en
tchétchénie qui se passe en kick and
kelly sont complexes physiques se
gêneront c'est tout petit complexe que
qui est pas du tout c'est quoi ces camps
les embarquer ça se voit pas il bosse à
six acteurs zac ne sont pas graves
sérieuses raisons jean-jacques est la
date anniversaire de votre rencontre
le 4 octobre 2004
[Applaudissements]
trois jours de deuil national
est ce que vous savez à quel âge il a eu
son premier rapport sexuel sur zac mais
4 octobre
bonnes réponses
finissons plus gros fantasmes
fantasme de jonzac ça n'est pas
comptable dans cette émission quand les
gens ne répondent pas ils sont pixelisé
pas de problème vous l'êtes pixelisé
pourvoira alors jean jacques qu'est ce
qui fut fait peur à pas rentrer chez toi
rien
6 6 6 pc quand qu'une guêpe euros d'un
petit peu autour de la table mais c'est
tout et c'est tout ah ouais tout là par
les guette à la peur ne
[Rires]
voulait arrêter d'être pixelisé ou les
engrais pitch est riche passé quand même
pas cool
[Musique]
oh
jean-jacques j'ai vues macro corrèze
mercredi je les ai vus aurillac
2 le bordel ils feraient mieux d'aller
regarder
parce qu'il y en a qui on les qualifie
mais je sais bien mais c'est pas loin de
dire non mais par la
manière forcée ça vous choque jean
jacques bourdin le franc parler du
président ce qui me choque c'est que il
sait qu'il y a les manifestants pas très
loin et donc ils ne résident pas tout de
même à dire mais il a dit ce qu'il
pensait il le pense sincèrement
ça me choque pas particulièrement
ça surprend aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le
politiquement correct est telle que je
ne peux plus rien des ces biens ne peut
plus rien dire il faut parler comme
françois hollande maintenant pour pas
être emmerdés qua non maintenant
maintenant c'est choquant quand on sait
qu'il y a dehors des hommes qui ont plus
de 50 ans et qui ne pourront pas aller
travailler à 145 kilomètres de chez eux
pourquoi et pourquoi parce que à 50 ans
où 52 ans il faut se former surtout
quand on travaille dans une entreprise
qui fait dans l'emboutissage
aller travailler dans une fonderie a 52
ans c'est un peu difficile quand on a
une maison une famille à deux heures de
route c'est un peu difficile mais mon
père il a déménagé toute sa vie pour
avoir du travail mais ils aller là où
est il travaille le père de ramzi
l'habitat haut rhin mais je rangeais sur
la base il y avait du travail en france
est par nature raison sur la mobilité je
ne peux pas attendre que le travail bien
à vous non mais je suis non mais là je
suis complètement d'accord c'est pour ça
que je dis que sur le fond il a raison
mais sur la forme l'endroit le lieu
alors qu'il sait qu'il ya des
manifestants dehors là c'est un peu plus
gênant que ça fasse le buzz que ça fait
ça me paraît pas tout non pas du fond on
parle d'économie et c'est la raison pour
laquelle plus personne ne croit en les
journalistes c'est la raison pour
laquelle le grand public dit les
journalistes sont des menteurs parce
qu'on est trop artificielle parce qu'on
fait trop attention aux choses qui sont
justement superficiel le journalistique
mans correct on en crève on en crève ça
vous choque vous que tout le monde
s'énerve parce qu'il a dit ça moi
robert roy taton et les enfants sont
partis
[Rires]
les chaînes de nouvelles en continu il
faut ouvrir la bête la belle sarah doc
moi je suis pour les gaffes ce que je
trouve qu' axa qui fait avancer le
schmilblick sinon tout le monde se
surveille pirelli qui arrivent en france
in gaza me robert ses revenus
non non je parle en général j'aime rica
j'aime les forêts d'appeler ça y est
mais quelqu'un qui dise qu'ils pensent
et oui sinon on s'en va où granby on l'a
perdu la vie sur la ville à sion on l'a
perdu j'étais sûr au tir tout n'est
[Applaudissements]
qu'un avis sur la question il n'a pas
quarante ans quand on parle parle comme
ça bon c'est vrai qui admet il ya les
gens juste derrière et puis doit savoir
qui a la caméra aussi mais j'ai il a
même pas 40 ans mais qu'on parle comme
ça fabrice pareil même même quand tu
présenter un film coliques printemps qui
fait attention à tout est mauvaise et
que le moindre truc peut te [__] en
l'air donc c'est ça devient très
compliqué
anaïs plus ça vous choque bon ça nous
choque pas ici ce qui est déjà très bien
voilà maintenant ah ben on va parler de
votre lille juste après et les vitres de
blacko
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
anne nivat est une reporter de guerre
qui va là où les autres ne vont pas
après l'irak l'afghanistan la
tchétchénie elle a donc décidé de
visiter laval evreux et montluçon dans
le temps on appelait ça la province
aujourd'hui on parle de la france
périphérique tandis que paris et les
grandes villes profitent de la
mondialisation dans le reste du pays les
temps sont durs
je travaille pour la république
française punit clivage droite-gauche
désormais c'est france d'en-haut france
d'en bas le second tour macro le pen
exprimait parfaitement ce nouveau visage
de la france ce qui les opposait c'était
leur vision de la mondialisation parce
que vous portez c'est l'esprit des fêtes
c'est expliquer à nos concitoyens c'est
trop dur la mondialisation pour nous
c'est trop dur l'europe le nouveau
président incarne la france d'en haut et
celle des grandes villes depuis cent
mille habitants qui ne représente que 40
% de la population mais qui produisent
deux tiers de la richesse du pays donc
son discours une attente à versailles
matheron avait d'ailleurs bien expliqué
que les petites villes de province ce ne
serait pas sa priorité je suis pour que
partout lorsqu'il ya des métropoles qui
réussissent lorsqu'il ya ces grandes
cités qui triomphent dans la
mondialisation on puisse les aider à
aller plus loin
comme le dit mélenchon jeu maquereau et
le président des riches la preuve à
paris l'immobilier et à 10000 euros le
mètre carré et macro obtenu 90 % des
voix au second tour pendant ce temps là
la france d'en bas s'inquiète mais reste
utilisé jaune
entre le pen qui voulait sortir de
l'euro et mélenchon qui ne parlent
jamais de l'immigration où vient des
candidats populistes nature rassembler
l'électorat populaire mais qui sait
l'amérique est du trump les bris nick
ont choisi briques site alors peut-être
qu'en 2022 la france d'en bas enverra
son candidat et qu'ils
étaient venus aux échos mise en image de
julien gracq gérois kaniv a applaudi qui
veut dire qu'elle n'a rien à redire sur
le sujet ça nous rassure
j'étais avec stéphane bakhos qui sait
pas s'il s'en souvient en hypokhâgne
pour ça je connais en bout il était pas
de fille géniale franchement la loi
relative à votre enquête dans quelle
france on vit est disponible à partir du
9 octobre en poche aux éditions curial
le déclarer quand on parle de la france
et les français
cela a plus de résonance que quand on
parle des irakiens des jaf quand c'est
vrai que j'ai passé un certain nombre
d'années à risquer ma vie pour raconter
la vie des autres à mes compatriotes
il n'avait pas forcément envie qu'on
leur a non mais c'est en même temps se
trouve c'est humain c'est très difficile
d'entendre parler toutes ces guerres qui
sont en dehors de notre monde mais il
faut quand même se rend compte qu'en
dehors de la bulle de confort dans
laquelle nous vivons tous plus ou moins
bien certes mais c'est quand même bill
de confort dans le sens où il n'y a pas
de guerre eh bien ça bouillonne ça
bouillonne et moi je pense je pense
qu'il faut qu'ils aient des gens qui
aillent dans le bouillon pour pouvoir
justement le racontez moi je fais rien
d'autre je suis pas la seule on est
quand même quelques-uns alors vous avez
donc décidé de tourner votre regard donc
sur l'hexagone en appliquant les mêmes
méthodes que pour découvrir les pays en
guerre elle est intéressée à la france
service enfance
et
matt
si les français se plaignent parfois
craquer
or celle ci est sous l'influencé de jean
jacques c'est à dire que moi avec
jean-jacques j'entends parler de la
france tous les jours il a tous les
jours les français au téléphone et moi
la même celui il faut le dire quand même
qu'il a inventé ça ils les écoutent où
les mêmes achats de regret dans la voix
oui voilà et moi je fais la même chose
mais généralement je le fais loin à
l'étranger dans des pays effectivement
compliqué l'irak l'afghanistan la syrie
la tchétchénie et mais je fais la même
chose et là j'ai décidé de le faire en
france ah ouais vous êtes intéressé à
l'emploi l'emploi à montluçon au niveau
du demandeur à laval du côté du patron
voilà ensuite le malaise des jeunes à
evreux points donc c'est des grands
problèmes dans des villes de 50000
habitants quant aux rythmes ajaccio où
c'est intéressant c'est vrai que
personne ne l'avait fait avant vous faut
avoir le courage souvient encore le
courage courage ne sait pas tirer à les
refouler alors montluçon je ne pense pas
qu'il faille beaucoup de courage je
pense qu'il faut uniquement de la
volonté dark dawn va pas se calmer mais
parce que vous voyez là comme ça très
directive est sûre de moi mais dans mon
métier je suis pas du tout comme ça
c'est à dire qu'il n'y a qu'une seule
chose qui m'intéresse c'est rentrer le
plus possible avec le plus de discrétion
possible dans la vie des gens pour
qu'ils me la raconte et que je puisse la
partager la transmettre nous allons
changer les traités le sentiment de
déclassement à laon oui j'étais faire
une tournée avec un facteur excellent
lens est au nord de paris c'est une
magnifique villa de hollywood est une
ville basse avec une cathédrale de laon
absolument sublime vous avez traité de
l'insécurité à lons le saunier et
lons-le-saunier petit relent jeudi
réplique à menton dans son sillage où il
n'y a pas du tout d'insécurité 1 dans
leur herti stick les gens y croient
intéresse vous savez bien c'est qu'on
n'a pas un statisme l'usiné gens de
talent là tout le monde se sent en
insécurité à lons le saunier comme
ailleurs donc une fois de plus je
détruire les stéréotypes et puis alors
on essaye l'identité ajaccio ouais parce
que j'aime la complication et que
l'identité je pouvais la traiter dans
plein de villes françaises mais ajaccio
j'ai rajouté une strate c'est à dire que
il ya l'identité française d' identité
arabe maghrébine des quartiers d'ajaccio
comme plein d'autres quartiers de france
et l'identité corse un troisième strate
donc là c'était absolument jamais
d'avoir les trois et de raconter la
réalité de ce que vous racontez
d'alleurs formidablement bien dans votre
film qui est une comédie et ça je trouve
ça génial c'est qu'il faut passer
peut-être par la comédie par le rire
pour pouvoir dire des choses que moi
malheureusement ce j'en suis encore à
essayer de raconter dans le réel mais je
pense qu'il faut les deux mais tout ça
c'est à cause du fait que les médias
prennent tout par les petites phrases et
qu'on peut plus rien dire avant donc on
a des comédies où on a des grands
reportages je suis juste à dire qu'on
traite l'actualité aujourd'hui par
l'anecdote ouais le traité l'actualité
sur leur actualité jean-jacques place
par dédain traite l'actualité par
l'anecdote c'est la culture du beurre
exactement and jésus votre bouquin
ça m'a donné envie de quitter le pays
vous comprenez dans ce bouquin justement
il ya de la réalité et dans la réalité
on oublie le côté positif c'est qu'il ya
de la fraternité c'est qu'il y a je
trouve que tous les français que j'ai
rencontrés sont capables de parler d'eux
mêmes et de leur vie qui est pas
forcément une vie folichonne certes mais
il en parle avec de l'humour de l'auto
humour et puis justement les yeux
ouverts moi j'ai pas envie on est dans
un monde de bisounours la conclusion la
morale que vous tirez de votre travail
la morale c'est qu'il faut vivre les
yeux ouverts et qu'il faut pas se
leurrer on est comme on est notre pays
va plus ou moins bien mais
il va en tout cas mieux que les pays
dans lesquels j'ai l'habitude d'aller
qui sont en guerre et c'est parce que
j'ai été dans ces pays en guerre et que
j'en suis revenue vivante c'est une
chance je suis revenu dans mon pays en
france où j'ai finalement quand même
beaucoup de chance de vivre que j'ai eu
envie de raconter comment vivaient dans
ce pays la
nuit va dans quelle france on vit c'est
publié en poche chez plurielles
et maintenant on passe à la question
sous serment
[Musique]
et
m
joël bourdin oui les yeux dans les reer
l'île saint louis les yeux dans les yeux
jurés vous que vous n'avez jamais désuni
avec un homme politique
déjeuner avec un homme politique ça
m'est arrivé peut-être une fois ouais et
il était plus en fonction mais c'était
quand louis borloo
s'était apaisé
après la bulle à 18 ans
[Musique]
rarement sur les terrains du samedi
génération sur terre toujours encore
dany d'un jean jacques bourdin
aline livrent leurs odeurs charlevoix
ramzy bedia fabrice éboué d'anaïs mali
et honda fit
et on passe maintenant un autre tu étais
où la semaine
oh
où
et
quand des agents la boire bonsoir
robert charlebois madame messieurs la
chose la plus étonnante qui soit venu du
québec avec le sirop d'érable et le nez
de céline dion
en parlant de ces lignes c'est vrai
qu'elle écoute plus personne mais puis
crohn et non non je crois que tu as
tellement écouté son mari que maintenant
alors
plus son mari travaille pour lille parce
que quand elle chantait elle parlait pas
de la journée à la face à chanter 3 164
g et le rêve
alors qu'elle fait là des sacs à main de
la mode a fait enfin même une de mes
chansons donc je peux pas en plein de
céline alors si toujours entendu dire le
jour où je perds mes cheveux j'arrête
oui
j'en ai perdu deux
mois et touche le cache pas mais je peux
je me masse de 3 ans et 10 mois les
cheveux ça ça vient du mélange avec les
indiens
animaux alors le premier charlebois qui
est parti au canada avec champlain donc
au xviiie siècle s'appelait jean way
soit ils partaient soit il était pendu
c'est un professeur d'école
je sais pas cette histoire mais s'était
jamais un peu des gibiers de potence
voilà et donc mon ancêtre a choisi le
canada bien que j'aimais la
potentialité de saint-macaire à 40 km de
bordeaux il ya toujours une maison
là-bas qui s'appelle à charlesbourg oui
oui tu es allé un peu picolé raid andré
dubois a été un des rares show que j'ai
ratés dans ma vie le le maire de la
ville m'attendais mais un avec la
ceinture la photo de giscard dernière
les pompiers en uniforme et on a bu le
rosé du bonheur leblanc de l'amitié le
rouge de l'amour le che thérapie le show
il ressemblait à ça aussi
alors quand il était petit on tape les
flash lite - c'est-à-dire torche parce
que tu t'es là comme ça et tout était
curieux tap les gares ou parce que tu
sortais la nuit et tu rentrais au petit
matin oui oui gallou avant l'eau de
galles ou non lodwick tapie qui tourne
en paya gallou premier
essai un copain et s'ils n'étaient pas
systématiques un jeune aurait poursuivi
parce que c'est moche est une compagnie
enregistrée limitée qui s'appelle les
productions gare ou un loup garou ne
pourrait pas sortir un parfum par
exemple sa gare où c'est à toi oui ça
moi alors ton et si les indiens
il a travaillé bourre pifs c'est un peu
de boxe et quad a pas tous là la chance
d'être alain delon et moi quand j'ai vu
arriver belmondo ou au cinéma dans quand
j'avais 16 ans je me suis dit
ça m'a un petit réconforter avec mon
physique je me suis dit enfin si lui est
capable de bien pourquoi pas pigé et
alors ce qui est marrant c'est que tu
dis que c'est la boxe que tu veut pas
avouer que tomber sur un mélange des
deux dit la vérité au bessat le lavabo
terai mais avoir un nez aquilin quand
même écoute moi moi j'ai du succès que
mon et donc c'est vrai que si j'avais le
choix je me serais fait refaire le nez
mais en plus le même il succédait alors
comme fabrice et ramzy tu as été un jour
ni téléphone transition sur les
données annoncées il ya un truc on se
moque pas du physique là sauf quand tu
as un négoce a
brisé abus tu as été élevé chez les
curés entasser les sulpiciens les
sulpiciens c'est pire que les jeunes je
sais ça n'a pas empêché de te droguer
mais c'est vrai que les suppliciés où
lennon lennon il appelait des directeurs
de conscience people vous faisait parler
parce que parce que jouer avec son corps
et a péché qui cite encore couler blast
est péché mortel alors ton corps at-il
couler
un brett a mal tourné il ya eu la pilule
à san francisco il arrive à san
francisco il ya une pilule qui vient de
sortir un truc de folie et les mecs
lully écouter la meilleure idée ça
serait quand même de la couper en quatre
parce que c'est dangereux ils ont coupé
en deux je les couper en deux parce que
nous on l'est du québec
résultat incapable de faire un numéro de
téléphone prend quinze jours incapable
de se souvenir de ton nom oui parce que
tu as beau mangé des steacks prend des
douches il faut dire aux gens il faut
dire aux gens de coquelles et en chine
autrement pensée dans ma carrière mais
il prend cette pilule un san francisco
et quand il revient il fait ça
sur québec air france venant de mr west
hill femmes américaines mais
[Musique]
aussi quand tu
vendus
[Musique]
g
on cite ici au soleil
elle est passée bon des
champions
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
c'est un guide passable oui mais
chef-d'oeuvre et il en a une centaine
d'imams acabit à 5 ans se rend pas
compte de la valeur de robert était un
génie un génie lindbergh louise
forestier
1968 énorme chanson qui m'a hyper
impressionné alors c'est vrai que les
paroles il y avait même une compagnie
qui a engagé des pigeons qui volaient en
dedans des eskimos bronzé qui tricotent
des ceintures fléchées farsi quand tu
l'as cannes la chanson est super mais il
aurait peut-être fallu couper la pilule
en quatre
j'abrège allah dieu écoute et le gars
qui me l'a vendu et après il ya eu ça ah
ben dis non
[Musique]
e
des fois j'ai plus le goût ne rien faire
voilà bien
[Musique]
la musique
j'adore revient
[Applaudissements]
je dors
[Musique]
j'ai besoin de voir l'image
les besoins
descendu
je t'aime comme
jetons
ainsi
je
j'en ai fait
m
mm
[Musique]
et passe
7 6
robert charlebois
est un
je peine cet homme est un demi dieu
alors robert charlebois 73 ans vous êtes
de retour en tournée dans toute la
france en mars et en avril 2018 à paris
au grand rex le 7 avril en est ce pas
c'est la tournée 50 ans de chanson la
tournée qui rajeunit personne
à bas tout augmente alors sur scène ya
cinq musiques aussi vous avez déclaré si
je prenais des musiciens de mon âge on
aurait l'air d'un gang de vieux cons et
ils ne sont qu il ya des rolling stones
qui font ça
et oui
la force et l'énergie l'aviez déjà et
c'est pour ça je m'en tout de moi aussi
je m'entoure de jeunes regardent mais
oui tu as raison alors lors de votre
premier passage à paris vous passiez en
première partie de georgette plana
women's adriana
[Musique]
c'est mieux
en tout
tandja
contre scène à l'olympia pour la
première fois avec georgette plana donc
tout le monde attend georgette pas lui
et effectivement ça dure un peu on ferme
le rideau et là vous étiez vous avez
jeté la batterie donc oui j'ai fait un
solo de batterie et et je pas le
meilleur bateau ville et donc les
morceaux ou enroulées dans la salle et
puis la légende voulait que j'avais
inventé le frisbee et d'angélique des
[Applaudissements]
crs content parce qu'aujourd'hui je les
aime je vous aime toi je t'aime c'est
marrant parce que des fois les émissions
des
weppes à saclay
ici la voix oui thierry il y a beaucoup
trop d'amour dans cette émission chances
de buzz s'est envolé je sais qu'il peut
y avoir un peu d'amour
qui sait
j'avais tissés
qui s'épanouit non c'est ian dury bravo
il ya un cadreur kiriaki répondu bravo
d'un jeu wii
des jeux sur les robert célèbre en
hommage à mon idole robert charlebois
alors tout le monde joue le premier qui
trouve le robert a gagné je vais d'une
déflation il a peur que tout le monde
baisse sa femme robert ménard
non témoin robert de niro
vient du noir et du secteur n'ont pas dû
tomber le pays nous choque pas je fais
mieux enrico macias que de commencer à
savoir une vanne mais
il partait en vacances avec papa maman
est la bonne robert de l'amour un point
heureux première l'amour
c'est dur ça c'est pour nous il a sauvé
la tête d'un tueur
2000 a répondu aussi
il ressemble un peu elizabeth taylor
bourré c'est un chanteur ouais assez
robert des cours oui robert smith bravo
regard
elizabeth taylor en bout et ils avaient
l'amour et la haine tatoué sur les
doigts ainsi robert mitchum robert
mitchum et charles laughton
et maintenant je vais appeler zemmour
enfin deschamps
je l'écris le super combiné pour un
arabe qui s'est trompé je me disais
aussi que dix huit on est plein d'autres
car après je vais lui dire je leur
apprends gage la forêt
il est passé de chaplin à iron man
robert downey junior comme
il a fait vendre plus de bière que
robert charlebois
un indice musicale peut-être
robert bob murray
m
[Musique]
il était avec zizou en 98 ah ben ça va
bien pires bravo à moi
et pour finir il nous a bien béziers
robert ménard
wever revient au maire
qui a gagné la seram du drame du casino
[Applaudissements]
on passe maintenant à un autre tu es qui
toi de la semaine
amaris mali rebond soir
19 note tékitoi de la semaine alors
selon le magazine lui qui envoie pas
c'est quand même un bon paquet vous
faites partie des quatre plus belles
filles de la planète
[Applaudissements]
santana
le monde
tout vous dire on se demande même si
vous n'êtes pas photoshopée dans la
vraie vie
incroyable alors en tout cas ça prouve
que la france est encore une grande
puissance et oui au niveau fille
alors anaïs moque gare ma vie vous êtes
né en
1992 à toulon 88 en fait j'ai dû mentir
parce que non quand j'ai signé à new
york on a dit est très belle et tout ça
mais ouais
j'étais trop vieille donc on m'a dit on
va mentir sur ton âge et c'est la
première fois que je le dis donc voilà
j'ai 29 ans bravo
messieurs
je suis vous avez vécu dix ans à nice
avec votre maman lui si c'est tchadienne
et votre père lui était polonais mais
vous parlez pas trop de lui non parce
que j'ai pas du tout conduit avec fille
j'ai vécu qu'avec ma mère il n'a jamais
été présent dans ma vie voilà alors
quand vous étiez petit vous étiez
complexé par vos cheveux ouais et c'est
le baby liste qui vous a sauvé la vie
vrai ou pas vrai je comprends bien des
sorts lycée
comme cantal un peu plus un pareil
j'étais le en peluche dans les écoles
privées catholiques et le seul petit
élève de couleurs et c'était en pleine
période arnold et willy est mon agent
non c'était arnold et willy
à 18 ans vous êtes repéré dans un pub à
annie mais votre mère lucie vous oblige
à finir les études exactement alors un
an et demi plus tard un autre agent vos
contacts sur facebook
et là c'est miraculeux il vous propose
de travailler à
[Musique]
petit fils cette émission pour écouter
de la musique tout le monde l'aura
compris jay-z alicia keys
face à dublin la ville est humble et tu
rentres dans le taxi ya un truc idiot
mais la vie est un blind données ne
soyez pas prosaïque rendez votre vie
poétique alors là vous êtes
immédiatement signé par la grande agence
ou les mines à votre carrière décolle
grâce aux vagues et surtout anna wintour
c'est à dire le diable s'habille en
prada et comment ça s'est passé avec
allaoui bon déjà j'ai dû changer d'agent
ce parce que je voulais faire boxe était
enfin si je vais être mannequin je
devais faire bugs et vous limina peut
pas m'apporter ça en fait donc je suis
parti chez ford et j'ai fait un rendez
vous avec un ami tout parce qu'avant de
2,9 dans le vague il faut l'a rencontré
dans son bureau et alors ça s'est passé
comment barrages les fait rire je sais
pas j'ai dû dire une connerie ça
l'affairé ouais parce que tu es tof
théâtre est atteint on a peur d'elle
tout le monde c'est le miracle
1 c'est vrai que contrairement à la
france sans jolie les boulin et défendez
remonte je comprends pas la logique de
quand elle descend déclare manque de
tout à l'heure au fait tu veux regarder
encore à l'effet wade sont tes boules un
miracle
le truc mais chez bfm tv
parce qu'ils bossent sur un fond vert
bien l'arc de triomphe et pas du tout il
faut en fond vert à la tour eiffel elle
est vrai tour eiffel c'est la vraie tour
eiffel on est dans un autre mandat
unique dimension cette notion est plus
d'état contrairement à la france à new
york on peut travailler quand on est
noir oui contrairement à la france oui
mais c'est comme ça ils sont comme ça
les français comme savoir vu que vous
avez à londres ou à new york vous rendez
compte des quel point les français sont
assis c'est vrai nom mais en fait je
avant de partir à new york j'ai tenté ma
chance à paris et j'ai été refusé parce
que voilà ouais je vais juste vous poser
une question vous pensez quoi de cette
loi marque un don pour lutter contre les
troubles alimentaires
je trouve que c'est bien ouais
apparemment on doit tout passer un test
médical ouais moi je n'ai pas encore
passé vous passer un test médical pour
votre indice de masse corporelle oui si
vous êtes inférieur à 18,5
vous n'avez pas le droit de travailler
en france voilà arielle dombasle
servette
l'autre chose c'est que quand une photo
et retoucher il faut marquer photos
retouchées voilà ah bon ouais alors
touché je vais être obligé de marquer en
dessous
retouché alors en plus d'être mannequin
vous dessinez des bodys oui des très
beaux baudis est une passion qui me gêne
votre maman c'est une passion qui
donnait aussi à ce qu'elle emportait
beaucoup voient là et je les volets
j'allais à l'école avec avait pas le
droit alors jean jacques si tu veux
offrir en body anaïs mali anne pour des
bodys par balles non plus
mais je vais lui en ouvrir de toute
façon
c'est votre première tv en france non
première je suis très fier
[Musique]
c'est elle a besoin de ce qu'on en sorte
que sur terre après la pub avec alex qui
sera
du samedi 20 heures marine d'un mariage
à 21 ans elle apprend qu'un st onge
blague à vannes
elle décide de partir d'une seule paire
le show du mont sacré nombreuses
[Musique]
ouah ouah bonsoir les terriens du samedi
jamais retour sur terre toujours en
compagnie de jean jacques bourdin
aline livrent leur honneur charlevoix
ramzy bedia fabrice éboué d'anaïs ma vie
et on remballe fille
et maintenant c'est l'heure des infos de
biseau
[Musique]
on soit thierry il recevra le trophée
voilà je le traite l'information je dois
donc commencer cette semaine par les
états unis après bowling for columbine
en a eu droit à strike in las vegas 59
morts et 500 blessés c'est arrivé
dimanche dernier et depuis on n'entend
plus kim jong-un il a dû renoncer à
éradiquer les américains jugeant qu'ils
arrivaient très bien tout seul alors
bien sûr cette fusillade relance le
débat récurrent aux états unis il faut
interdire les amenons faut-il oui ou non
interdire la musique country thierry
évidemment mais oui l'auteur a tiré
depuis vais très très bonne réplique
tirée l'auteur je sais que je peux me
faire confiance attiré depuis sa chanson
de molière ouais il ya quelquechose ya
quelque chose dans le judo du travail
progressivement l'auteur a tiré de sa
chambre du 32e étage de l'hôtel mandalay
bay où il séjournait il a d'ailleurs
laissé à une très bonne appréciation sur
tripadvisor on l'a ici belles chambres
vue imprenable sur le parc environnant
et surtout possibilité d'amener beaucoup
de bagages
l'assaillant était blanc de 60 ans mais
dans le doute darche a revendiqué la
fusillade partant du principe que le
droit d'auteur en matière d' attentat
n'est pas clair clair il n'y a pas
encore de sacem du terrorisme et c'est
bien content parce qu'avec l'audience
que ça fait sur bfm tv il ya du pognon à
ce faire
mais voilà une fine il s'agissait juste
d'un déséquilibré l'occasion évidemment
de rappeler le vocabulaire a utilisé aux
états unis quand un arabe tuent des gens
c'est un terroriste quand un blanc tuent
des gens c'est un déséquilibré sauf s'il
tue un noir là c'est un policier à
partir
et conséquence merveilleuse de
l'attentât le cours des vendeurs d'armes
s'envole à wall street c'est chouette et
c'est là que l'expression la bourse ou
la vie prend tout son sens notons enfin
cette prise de position forte céline
dion maintient ses concerts à las vegas
après la fusillade dahesh hésitent à
prendre
et comment cette semaine parler
d'attentât sans avoir une pensée
évidemment pour les victimes de la gare
saint charles à marseille entre le paris
saint-germain et l'état islamique c'est
à se demander ce que le qatar a contre
marseille en ce moment
passons à la politique française
[Musique]
et on commence par une toute bonne
nouvelle qui réjouira tout le monde
l'exécutif va recruter deux experts pour
aider bruno le maire et gérald darmanin
alors c'est vrai que ça aurait été
complètement idiot de mettre aux
finances et au budget directement des
experts comme ministre et les faits n'a
pas traîné isf darmanin favorable à une
taxation des produits ostentatoire tels
que les yachts donc produit ostentatoire
ben c'est ce qui est cher et qu'ils
voient mais alors juste qu'on valait est
ce que si tu as un iphone dit c'est bien
tu payes des sms que si tu es joey starr
tu dois déclarer tes dents en or et si
ta femme va coûter une fortune en
chirurgie esthétique doit-on te taxe est
arrivé moi je m'en fiche mais c'est pour
bernard henri lévy ça pourrait plomber
son année comme
[Applaudissements]
mais rassurez vous bonnes gens malgré
tout ça le porte parole du gouvernement
christophe castaner a déclaré à propos
de macron il est le président des
pauvres au quotidien
appelons le désormais soeur emmanuel
macron
façon au front national
sur facebook la sénatrice fn claudine
kaufmann compare les migrants aux nazis
alors pour une fois que le fn fait un
compliment migrants d'aller leur
reprocher je trouve ça nul à gauche le
canard enchaîné dévoile que raquel
garrido n'aurait pas payé ses
cotisations retraite depuis six ans
et oui mais thierry va falloir augmenter
le salaire la pauvre elle a du mal on en
parlera demain bien joué le coup du
teasing
en tout cas on connaît la nouvelle
devise des insoumis insoumis deux côtés
est un sou prix sur les os
[Applaudissements]
international à présent donald trump il
a minimisé l'ouragan maria par rapport à
katrina à porto rico dans son discours
devant les rescapés il a dit ce n'est
pas comme si vous aviez connu une vraie
catastrophe comme katrina pas quoi les
portoricains répondu ce n'est pas comme
si nous étions face à un vrai président
américain comme obama et puis trump a eu
ce geste improbable
il a lancé des rouleau de sopalin alain
population alors c'est vrai qu'après un
bon ouragans pour se remettre un petit
branlette s'étant même un show
[Applaudissements]
international toujours évidemment le
référendum en catalogne les autorités
catalanes revendique 90 % de oui 90% à
une élection en fait la catalogne elle
veut quitter l'espagne pour devenir un
état africain et cette semaine pour
protester contre la répression policière
du référendum le fc barcelone a joué son
match de championnat à huis clos un
stade vide pour soutenir une cause c'est
beau mais il faudrait peut-être prévenir
les supporters de monaco qu'ils peuvent
revenir maintenant ça fait longtemps que
la principauté a eu son indépendance
[Applaudissements]
société à présent avec cette info solo
gami l'italienne laura mais si c'est
épouser on a le droit de ces poussées
soi même donc quand il a entendu ça
alain delon a repris nous arrive mais
qu'est ce qu'ont bien pu lui offrir ses
amis à l'orage impact de 12 piles
rechargeables pour le voyage de noces
voyage de noce où on va pas se mentir
elle aura beaucoup de difficultés à se
surprendre quant à la destination et
jeux sony va que si vous aviez le choix
allez pas vous auriez hésité entre vous
épousez vous même épousé jean jacques
bourdin chichi à ne pas vous mentir je
sais que vous vous aimez beaucoup je
regarde votre instagram alors si vous
voulez voilà est alors un petit peu et
alors cessé mais beaucoup que de montrer
des photos de soi comme tout le monde
quand on fait du sport et qu'on aime la
veille
alors vous allez avoir levé et je vous
donne une info la photo de gauche est
prise par mon mari mes félicitations le
problème est donc ont mis la photo shop
le plus d'abonnés
[Applaudissements]
touchés
puisqu'on est dans le teasing et arrière
du dimanche
jeremstar va se poser lui même et ça
commence demain soir dans les terriens
du dimanche au téléphone
en tout cas je suivais hans urs vous
préfériez tout ce que je sois moche
mais c'est pas la vérité voilà moi et
vous à faire je suis très bien dans le
rapt reporter de guerre aux poursuites
voyez le problème c'est qu'il ya des
motifs je crois que vous connaissez ça
aussi vous enrayée alors le stéréotype
de la femme reporter de guerre c'est
qu'elle est moche mal dans sa peau
qu'elle a raté sa vie c'est si je vous
dis tout bon succès et alors moi je suis
je m'amuse beaucoup ak c'est tout ça et
à démontrer le contraire on est tous
d'accord people
antoine griezmann va chanter avec les
[__] ouais oui j'avoue ça m'a
surpris c'est quand même une star
antoine griezmann qu'est-ce qui va
[__] là bas
mais surtout pourquoi un footballeur les
mecs se font déjà prier pour chanter la
marseillaise en short sous la flotte et
on voudrait qu'il chante du bénabar
déguisé en carotte à côté de mimie mathy
en rade est
brève
et je commence par celle ci si vous ne
riez pas quand vos amis rient peut-être
être vous un psychopathe laurent baffie
il fallait commencer à se poser votre
question je ne suis pas qu'un violeur je
serai également un psychopathe profil je
l'éprouvé tout à l'heure avec
france encore
un drone confisqués après avoir survolé
le sanctuaire de lourdes alors bon déjà
ça a dû surprendre tout le monde on
n'imaginait pas qu'il faisait autant de
bruit le saint-esprit mais surtout à
lourdes les saints qui ont le droit de
voler ce sont ceux qui te vendent à 30
euros la petite fiole d'eau miraculeuse
et la dernière nous vient du nord ivre
le jeune marié veut brûler la voiture de
son rival et se trouve de véritables
alors c'est peut-être pas un hasard si
on a mis le nord juste à côté de ma
belgique
et on termine thierry par la culture
anne hathaway je propose chaque semaine
une petite visite culturelle et cette
semaine venez à bruxelles découvrir le
jeune artiste franco marocain qui vit à
travailler en belgique mehdi georges
lahlou il explose au botanique à
bruxelles jusqu'au 5 novembre
l'exposition s'appelle behind the garden
alors c'est 'qui en belgique d'appeler
une exposition derrière le jardin un vu
que la dernière fois qu'on a exposé ce
qui se trouvait derrière un jardin
c'était celui de marc dutroux alors
l'artiste un père marocain musulman est
une maman espagnol catholique et on
comprend mieux son vrai nom mehdi
georges intime hashid que ses parents
avaient un vrai sens du compromis et
mehdi georges lahlou n'hésite pas à se
moquer des religions je pense qu'il va
vous plaire fabrice et ramzy première
oeuvre ici une installation où on voit
les tapis de prière avec que des
chaussures d'homme et puis une paire de
chaussures de femmes oeuvre qui aurait
pu s'appeler louboutin akbar
la suivante si on reconnaît
l'inspiration christine angot lisant un
livre pour on n'est pas couché
[Applaudissements]
une autre oeuvre qui risque de vous
plaire 72 vierges elle s'appelle
représente 72 buste au voile blanc
immaculé une vraie provocation temps il
est aberrant pour des vierges de ne
garder que ce qu'il y à au dessus des
épaules c'est de l'anti polanski et
c'est une thématique qui lui plaît
puisque autres oeuvres 72 vierges dans
le vent il a appelé ses lattes et
souhaits laurent baffie mais la voile
alors moi la dernière fois que j'avais
vu un truc du genre c'était en allant
voir ma mamie à la maison de retraite un
jour où il faisait sécher des draps
après une épidémie de gastro mais voilà
je vous conseille cet homme quand même
revenons à mehdi georges lahlou et c'est
très beau un homme qui aime se mettre en
scène dans ses oeuvres notamment celles
ci un oeuvre qu'il appelle ceci n'est
pas une femme musulmane ou non non ceci
est une tentative d'imitation raté débit
kacou
est ici ici aussi
voilà une belle oeuvre et on peut le
voir comme ça on peut le soupçonner
d'avoir jouer dans le remake marocain de
prison break une autre ici voilà bon
alors c'est vrai qu'on dirait un extrait
de thé pmp avec cyril hanouna qui aurait
demandé à mathieu delormeau de se mettre
soi qui jamais n'ont
alors un plus il aime la religion mais
il aime aussi tout ce qui se mange et on
va le voir sur le prochain happening où
il se fait asperger de couscous une
oeuvre qui a énormément plu à florian
philippot évidemment et puis la dernière
ma préférée oeuvre voilà où il répond
très certainement une question que tout
le monde se pose mais comment diable
fait philippe croizon pour revenir du
lidl
à la semaine prochaine
allez célébrer avec nous jean jacques
bourdin merci d'avoir été avec pour
l'aja
et on pense maintenant à notre carrière
du samedi soir
[Musique]
marine barnérias bonsoir
vous avait 21 ans quand on vous annonce
que vous êtes atteinte d'une sclérose en
plaques est là plutôt que de continuer à
faire la tournée des neurologues pour
trouver un traitement efficace vous
décidez de partir en voyage tout seul
pour vous recentrer sur vous-même et
apprivoiser votre maladie un périple
initiatique en océanie en asie que vous
racontez marine dans un livre intitulé
c'est pereiro le voyage interdit qui a
donné un sens à ma vie publié chez
flammarion et ce soir dans salut les
terriens
[Musique]
marine vous êtes né le 26 novembre 1993
à 5 e dans le 92 mais deux scolarisés
dans une école privée catholique blanche
de castille aux chaînés oui décidément
c'est la soirée y a pas une personne ici
qui n'ai pas été éduqué dans une école
catholique à pied - oui toi oui ça se
voit
alors votre père journaliste votre mère
assistante de direction dans une grosse
entreprise d'imprimerie
les cinq ans quand vos parents divorcent
mais vous ne vivez pas mal en fait ça
vous autonomise c'est ça absolument
c'est vrai que je pense que le divorce
peut diviser mais là je pense que ça m'a
permis aussi de me recentrer et d'avoir
une autonomie que j'aurais peut-être pas
pu avoir la voilà sans ce divorce qui
est devenu une force en fait pour sa
part quelque chose malheur est bon
à 14 ans vous partez dans une pension à
compiègne ensuite ça sera à amiens
devient un vrai besoin de liberté déjà
étant ado kwa je pense que j'avais
besoin de me retrouver dans ce nom c'est
petite banlieue aussi on est on est vite
externalisée un peu de nous meurt donc
j'avais besoin de de voir d'autres
horizons et de rencontrer d'autres
personnes aussi alors vous continuer vos
études à lille et là dans une semaine
vous perdez des usages de votre main
gauche vous ne savez pas pourquoi
ensuite vous continuer vos études à
marseille vous avez 20 ans d'être jolie
vous êtes dynamique fait du jogging 7
heures du matin c'est pas rien
mais vous faites aussi la fête jusqu'à
point d'heure quoi vous avez une vie de
voyages étudiante en école de commerce
tout va bien le 3 avril 2015 vous
participez avec votre bds un tournoi
sportif entre écoles de commerce et de
management et le lendemain vous réalisez
que votre vue périphérique
diminue progressivement vous mettez ça
sur le compte de la peinture je peux pas
penser que c'est ça ce qui se passe
c'est que là je perds la vie du jour au
lendemain ouais donc c'est vrai que
quand on a une vie un petit peu à cent à
l'heure quand on est étudiant et toutes
les couleurs un peu à droite à gauche
laon justement je voyais plus obligés de
tourner d'envoyer par amnésie voilà par
exemple
patent plaisir ouais vous mettez de ça
donc sur le compte de la peinture mais
plus la journée passe plus vous avez mal
à la tête et quand votre équipe gagne le
trophée vous vous rendez compte que vous
voyez mal le trophée c'était justement
un concours qui a été gagnée mais un peu
à moitié puisqu'ils avaient mieux
commencé à se faire la malle donc
lendemain les symptômes sont encore plus
présents la netteté a disparu de voir un
ophtalmo
et l'obtenons vous dit ça n'a rien à
voir avec la vue c'est vrai que moi
j'arrivais pour une allergie avec de la
peinture et je me retrouve parachuté en
moins de cinq minutes aux urgences donc
au début je me dis bon il ya un petit
problème et est en fait cette amérique
c'est à dire que ça fait longtemps vous
allez voir un neurologue qui vous
analyse et là c'est terrible neurologue
lui lit écoute et aller chez vous prenez
vos affaires et revenez parce qu'on est
obligé de vous garder une semaine
l'hôpital dont vous au départ fait un
truc bon j'y vois pas bien sauf que là
le neurologue lui cassent complètement
en vous demandant de venir habiter à
l'hosto moyenne casse complètement parce
que c'est vrai que je m'attendais
absolument pas et hospitalisé une
semaine et puis ça va durer encore un
peu plus longtemps quand vous revenez à
l'hôpital maxime votre jules et là c'est
comme une super surprise quoi
c'est vrai qu'il était absolument pas à
marseille donc quand je l'aï appelé pour
lui dire que je me faisais hospitalisé
je suis venu avec mes petites valises
dans l'hôpital et lui il était là il est
bien c'est maxime alors à l'hosto les
scammeurs succèdent aux irm vous êtes
isolé vous voyez rien on vous injecte
des doses massives de cortisone non les
effets secondaires de la cortisone c'est
très bizarre sont de droit où on a des
montez justement le foriic de joie et
puis de secondes après on est dans une
dépression est aussi absolument deux
semaines plus tard le neurologue vous
dit vous avez la sclérose en plaques
impossible de dire un mot là le saviez
ce que c'était déjà ou non ceux déjà je
trouvais que c'était un mot très laid ce
qui veut dire la seule ça va mais la
sclérose en plaques les emplettes sait
déjà c'est quelque chose que j'ai tourné
dans des films et ça arrive toujours aux
autres en fait et quand ça tombe sur soi
on réalise absolument pas voulu en laine
avec la tête dans l'oreiller parce que
vous êtes place un vous regardez votre
maman et vous lui dites est ce que
maxime la bouilloire d'une handicapée
c'est votre première réaction c'est ma
première réaction minière punaises j'ai
20 ans j'ai 21 ans à l'époque c'est une
maladie on me l'a expliqué très
rapidement qui est une maladie auto
immune qui ne m'avait dit qu'il ne rôde
dégénérative c'est à dire que moi
j'avais perdu la vue j'avais perdu comme
vous le disiez très bien ma main gauche
avant et c'est une maladie qui peut qu
elle est dans l'évolution donc je me
suis dit mais comment je vais pouvoir
dire à mon compagnon justement que il
peut il peut peut-être être en couple
avec une personne qui peut être en
fauteuil roulant bientôt alors le
neurologue vous donne une brochure vous
expliquer ce qu'est la sclérose en
plaques
il vous dit qu'il repassera le lendemain
enfin serait jamais revu non c'est vrai
que l'annoncent diagnostic quand on vous
dit vous avez une sclérose en plaques je
vais finir ma tournée et puis je reviens
et puis on vous donne rien on vous donne
gestion brochure sur votre lit d'hôpital
c'est un peu étrange quand même comme
annonce alors là vous apprenez
effectivement comment fonctionne maladie
c'est-à-dire par poussées successives on
va avoir une poussée puis après pendant
deux ans n'a rien qui apprendra une
autre poussée ainsi de suite en fait
c'est une maladie comme toutes les
maladies je pense qui est individuel à
chaque être humain il n'y a pas une
sclérose en plaques qui se ressemblent
comme il n'y a pas un cancer qui se
ressemblent je pense que c'est vraiment
la personne qui la développe d'une
manière ou d'une autre la vous entamer
un marathon des neurologues
vous n'êtes pas convaincu parce qu'aucun
ne vous donne vraies réponses les mêmes
voire un magicien guérisseur en belgique
il met ses mains sur la tête après avoir
vu une dizaine de leurs homologues je me
dis bon la solution elle est pas chez
eux je vais essayer d'aller voir
quelqu'un d'autre qui est un petit peu
de magnétisme dans un canton à un
diagnostic comme ça qu'ils t'ont on est
tellement d'une l'érable qu'on externe
est ensuite les possibilités tout avait
retrouvé une soluce à fait
compréhensible de chercher n'importe
quelle solution dans ces cas là donc en
réalité votre maladie malheureusement
est incurable et vous réalisez à ce
moment là que la solution viendra de
vous les passe de l'extérieur et vous
décidez c'est très important ça de vous
écouter vous
oui alors ça n'était pas du tout une
évidence au début ça a mis du temps
justement de comprendre que avant
d'aller rechercher ce que l'autre
pouvait me conseillez fallait déjà que
moi je me retrouve antérieurs non que je
sois malade ou pas en tous les cas alors
plutôt que de vous reposer parce que
normalement vous dise reposez vous
reposez vous pas du tout il envoie vous
avez pris le contrôle de votre vie vous
poursuivez votre stage à euronews et
puis vous vous mettez là pour l'instant
dans un certain déni de la maladie vous
commencé à écrire un petit carnet espèce
de thérapie personnelle je pense que
l'état il y avait beaucoup de choses que
je n'arrivais pas à verbaliser et il y
avait mon coeur qui bouillonnait
d'émotion qui bouillonnait plein de
choses qui n'arrivait pas s'exprimer et
les crimes a m'a aidé à mettre des mots
que j'aurais jamais réussir réussi à
sortir votre nom en fait malheureusement
trois mois et demi plus tard 3e
poussez-vous reperdait la vue là vous
commencez à accepter votre maladie et
vous décidez à ce moment-là de vous
recentrer sur l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
le corps l'esprit et l'âme ah non c'est
vrai que c'est ce corps cet esprit et
cette âme est venu grâce à ses petites
notes que vous racontiez justement quand
j'écrivais quand j'ai perdu la vue une
deuxième fois je me suis replongé dans
ses notes et là il ya juste quelque
chose qui est arrivé mais droit dans ma
fille lieu où je me suis dit mais la
corrélation entre mon corps et mes
pensées c'est hyper important je pense
que j'avais mon corps qui grandissait
sur une planète et mon esprit qui
grandissent
alors vous partez seul avec un sac à dos
en fait vous aviez jamais fait de
camping jamais fait de road trip avait
22 ans nous baptisé votre projet ses
pairs héros ses pairs comme cep rester
aux en plaques et héroïne vous récoltez
13000 euros
sur un site de financement participatif
de croo fumer vous baptisé votre maladie
rosie
avec comme symbole la rose et là vous
d'essayer de distribuer des roses
d'herbault vous retourner la table en
fait c'est ça qui est génial je pense
que c'était aussi la solution
transformer quelque chose de laid je
pense que les mots on devient on devient
new moore et la sclérose en plaques on
l'a devient aussi avec se moquer sifflé
et transformé une sclérose en rose ouais
je voyais beaucoup plus les pétales que
les arguments fait ce serait bien
le 27 janvier 2016 vous vous envoler
pour la nouvelle-zélande
là bas vous vous concentrer sur votre
corps pour dézinguer l'actualiser la
maladie à la part mais à quel probable
parce que ce qu'il faut dire quand même
c class heroes en plaques ça provoque de
la paranoïa vous décidez d'être moins
dans la pensée d'être plus dans le
physique c'est vrai puisque en fait là
la sclérose en plaques ya pas de temps
on nous dit pas qu'on va être handicapée
à telle heure à telle moment donc dès
qu'on a une sensation corporelle quelle
qu'elle soit soit des fourmillements ou
quelque chose qui me gratte quelque
chose qui me démangent je me disais
pinet c'est ma petite rosicky commencent
à s'activer et c'est vrai de réapprendre
à vivre avec son corps et à écouter les
corvées le corps je pense connaître
grâce une personne vous rester trois
mois en nouvelle zélande fait du stop
avec une pancarte
don't worry and cool
c'est vrai que le stock c'était une
manière pour moi de gérer mon stress
aussi parce que je pense que l'ennemi
premier de toutes maladies confondues
c'est quand même ce stress et voyager en
stop ça m'a permis justement d'être face
à ces imprévus qui était constante hier
il n'y a pas eu de mauvaises rencontres
en trois mois mais écoutez c'était
exceptionnel parce que non et j'ai eu
que des petites que des petites étoiles
rencontre extraordinaire à un moment
vous quittez le groupe d'allemands avec
qui vous êtes vous descendez la montagne
vous trouvez une fille qui est assise
sur un tronc d'arbre avec la tête entre
les mains c'est bel team est elle à
serge en plaques quoi espèce de
rencontre absolument magique quoi messi
exceptionnel parce que c'est vrai que je
pense que quand on se connecte vraiment
à notre corps il ya des sensations et il
ya des choses que jamais de la vie
j'aurais écouté jory ressenti à van est
en haut de cette montagne j'avais mon
corps qui me faisait redescendre j'avais
pas encore finie cette marche et je me
suis mise à redescendre d'un coup
vraiment comprendre pourquoi est arrivé
en bas je tombe sur cette fameuse femme
j'échange quelques mots avec elle on est
perdu au fin fond de la nouvelle zélande
a et elle a aussi une rosie
malheureusement qui lui a piqué un petit
peu plus les genoux et les mollets donc
elle avait du mal justement à monter sur
cette montagne c'est incroyable mais
aussi en 4/4 donc le type il vous prend
en stop il a une voiture automatisée en
fait il a aussi une rosie
j'arrive il s'arrête j'avais absolument
pas remarqué qu'il était complètement
justement au top un handicapé
automatisés et puis là je on échange et
à la fin de la conversation je lui
explique que je voyage pour marosi et là
on se serrent dans les bras il
m'explique que lui aussi a une à une
rosie ça a été un moment très très fort
parce que toutes ces rencontres sur ce
chemin je suis tout seul à l'autre bout
du monde en nouvelle zélande et j'ai
rencontré des dizaines de si alors
qu'avant dans ma vie j'en avais pas
rencontrer une vous donne de la force
tip il me donne n'est plus que de la
force je pense que c'est une force qui
est inimaginable que je pourrais même
pas expliquer et trouver les mots pour
retranscrire la force qui m'a donné
ensuite d'aller en thaïlande pour deux
semaines le temps de faire des papiers
pour aller en birmanie et la à
l'aéroport de bangkok méga surprise
maxime ah oui en génial sodexo est là
oui je crois qu'il est juste là la
maxime
il est où
m
[Applaudissements]
allez
borloo
[Applaudissements]
eq laurent marie c'est moi qui t'ai
piégé mais on voulait devoir d'apporter
très beau gosse et ensuite elle très
jolies gonzesses et on est
alors en thaïlande vous rencontrez
elyonor qui est une avocate franco
espagnole pareil elle a déjà fait comme
blue circle à la même maladie que vous
mais elles voyagent déjà pour la même
expérience incroyable elle voyage pour
se retrouver aussi à même s'il y avait
elle avait plein de solutions de
traitement aussi elle avait besoin de se
retrouver ça a bien fonctionné pour elle
alors empire mamie vous partez à la
conquête de votre esprit ou méditer vous
apprenez bien avec vous même c'est
important la birmanie se passe quelque
chose en birmanie mais écoutez je pense
qu'il y avait un mot que je ne
connaissais pas dans ma liste et le
silence je pense que ça se voit on veut
je pars un peu tout le temps mais ce mot
silence pour moi m'effrayer énormément
et j'ai découvert à quel point le
silence tous les beaucoup plus parlé que
les mots en fait vous avez dans un
monastère voilà vous devez rester dix
jours sans parle pas ce que je pourrais
passer dix jours sans parler du conflit
né sur son par les souliers ni lire ni
écrire mais voilà alors il faut pas
croiser le regard pas parler pas écrire
évidemment alors 24 heures après vous
craquez vous allez voir la référente
qu'est-ce que vous le dites je lui
demande si je vais si je vais rester là
même marine et si je vais pas sortir
après dix jours complètement transformée
elle me regardait lequel habitude de
méditer tout le temps elle explose de
rire donc moi ça faisait 24 heures que
personne ne m'avait regardé là elle me
regarde elle explose de rire mais
c'était exceptionnel pour moi elle me
regarde avec un air mais elle masi mais
marine tu vas pas de transformer en
bouddha après dix jours et ça m'a fait
du bien et ça m'a fait un bien fou cette
conversation qui a duré exactement 10
secondes et après je suis reparti vous
distribue le vérose oui c'est votre
grand truc en fat a distribué des roses
c'est vrai que les roses pour moi ça a
été dans le 2ème monastère ça a été une
force parce que je trouve que la maladie
on peut la rendre tellement fleury on
peut vraiment la fleurir d'une manière
très positive est ce ce geste de
distribuer et rose m'a autant apporter
que des gens qui n'ont reçu je pense
[Applaudissements]
alors mon bolide concentrer sur l'âme et
vous participez à une transhumance donc
c'est à dire que vous faites 8h02 cheval
par jour oui en silence
voilà j'avais ouais il avait pas de
choix vous comprenez pas ce qu'ils
racontent et alors elle est le mogul
c'est un peu compliqué alors vous partez
avec muji et jusqu'à la frontière russe
et vous rencontrez des tatars et de
satam c'est un peuple had qui élèvent
des reines dans la taïga attend très
très loin les de sa tête ça a été une
expérience exceptionnelle avec ce fameux
moggi que j'embrasse même si mme
entraînera jamais mais vous taillez
dubois voutré y ait des reines et moi
qui avais jamais campé de ma vie
découvrez tout ça depuis non là c'était
vraiment du du du sauvage de hazen lui
mois plus tard vont rentrer en france
et vous découvrez que ya huit mois qu'on
n'avait pas eu de pousses et de rosie
mais c'est vrai que c'est laid sclérose
en plaques quand c'est les paralysies
m'ont dit que ça s'appelle des poussées
dès que j'ai perdu la vue une deuxième
fois j'ai voulu partir retrouvez ce
corps cet esprit cette arme et là ça
fait deux ans justement que ma petite
rose imap a piqué donc c'est pas un
discours de guérison loin de là
maintenant c'est vraiment un discours de
cohabitation pour se dire que dans la
vie on a mille lieues d'imaginer ce qui
ce qui peut jaillir de l'intérieur de
notre coeur quand on commence à
s'écouter je pense et c'est la première
fois de ma vie que je me suis écouté
j'espère sera pas la dernière
super histoire rien à dire la seule
chose qu'on peut dire c'est voilà c'est
avec jacques
holmes
robert
hamdi
fabrice
alice
harry
à tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à faire cette
émission rendez vous demain à 19h05 et
les terriens du dimanche et d'ici là ces
mythes point fr pour voir l'émission
n'oubliez pas les terriens n'ont peur de
rien
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu